salut à vous peuple d internet et et et
bienvenue dans ce ce décor un petit peur
au modelé pour décembre
et pourquoi le côté je suis veux le dire
pourquoi c'est très simple puisque du
1er au 24 décembre j'ai décidé cette
année de vous faire un calendrier de
l'avent
hier je je ne suis pas le chocolat mais
cette chaîne sera un calendrier de
l'avent tous les jours du 1er au 24
décembre aura une vidéo qui sortira à 6
heures du matin sur la chaîne
pourquoi six heures parce que je musique
c'était pas mal en fait peut-être avant
d'aller en cours ou mais a comme ça 6
heures il n'est pas obligé de mettre son
réveil à 5h59 par exemple c'est pas
grave si je la regarde à midi voilà le
principe l'idée c'est que sur ces 24
vidéo je vais vous faire des vidéos un
petit peu normal un petit peu style le
mental blog vous savez meyer a la
particularité que à chaque fois je vous
présenterai quelque chose que j'ai à moi
ou que je vais acheter spécialement pour
la vidéo qui sera une idées de cadeaux
de noël potentiel pour vous pour
quelqu'un alors attention on est bien
d'accord idée de cadeau pour les gens
qui aiment les trucs un petit peu dans
mon délire parce que par exemple si
c'est pour quelqu'un qui est fan de
mécanique automobile
je suis pas sûr de le passionner avec
des choses qui me passionnent mois cette
introduction est beaucoup trop longue
je précise aujourd'hui j'essaierai de ne
pas le préciser à chaque fois mais il
s'agit pas de placement de produit c'est
quand même important de le dire
tous les objets dont je vous parlais
sont toujours dans la description ainsi
que d'autres hits et cadeaux ça peut
être une place pour venir me rejoindre à
l'olympia le 22 septembre 2018 en voilà
une idée cadeau qu'elle est très bonne
pour faire ce spectacle ensemble
voilà vous êtes toujours un lien vers
mon lit et fernand jeux etc mais ce
n'est pas le propos
on n'est pas là pour faire le taux promo
sinon ça serait la chaîne s'affairaient
fabien olicard comme c'est la vidéo
numéro une c'était vraiment aussi pour
vous posez vous expliquer le concept
mais j'ai quand même vous faire voir un
bouquin c'est un escape book
alors c'est quoi c'est la rencontre
entre les livres dont vous êtes le héros
et les espèces room ou des escape game
c'est à dire c'est saloum
devait sortir en 60 minutes chrono et il
ya une maison d'édition 404 édition ils
ont décidé de faire sa version papier et
ça marche très très bien ça c'est le
nouveau qui est sorti la veille le piège
de mort et arty et en clair vous allez
résoudre une enquête pour sherlock
holmes vous êtes vous êtes un agent de
scotland yard et vous allez devoir
résoudre cette enquête dont kharga bien
nous vraie histoire au départ et après
il ya des indices des énigmes à résoudre
des labyrinthes à l'intérieur même du
livre c'est vraiment très très fun je
sais pas si vous avez connu les livres
dont vous êtes le héros
d'ailleurs vous a envoyé apparaître
quelques uns autour de moi bravo lorie
hatami celui-ci j'adorais ça me permet
de vous dire que c'est peut-être pas moi
qui vais monter toutes ces vidéos etc à
chaque fois que je ferai ça il ya
quelqu'un derrière son nez quand tu as
ta faut vraiment que je rajoute une
image là eh bien oui tout à fait bref
c'est bien au delà d'une énigme simple
tu vis une vraie histoire quand tu fais
ça et dans cette histoire-là tas de
rebondissements etc il ya une difficulté
qui est qui est en fait une difficulté
comme j'aime quand dans certains jeux
vidéo ça me fait aussi c'est à dire
c'est pas trop simple mais tard en sera
toujours tu seras jamais réellement
bloqués si vous voulez vraiment un livre
d'énigmes pour vous prendre la tête à
mort sans trouver de solution j'en ai
plein d'hôtels ou conseiller ça c'est
vraiment fun et d'avancer quoi qu'il
arrive d'avancé juste que tu participes
vraiment c'est assez interactif je
trouve ça cool de cette édition-là de
chez 404 j'avais fait le premier c'est
pour ça que j'ai acheté le deuxième
c'était prisonniers des morts là c'était
vraiment dans l'univers des zombies donc
rien à voir on n'est plus dans un truc
du style walking dead la simplement dans
l'univers sherlock holmes
né en 1890 1891 dans le bouquin j'ai à
peine commencé donc pas vous en dire
plus
et puis je vais pas vous spolier même si
vous avez déjà fini voilà c'est
tellement mon idée cadeau de noël qu'est
ce que vous en pensez qu est ce que vous
pensez de cette idée aussi là de faire
une vidéo par jour pendant 24 jours en
hôtel en dribbles avant
dites le moi dans mes commentaires parce
que si jamais ça vous plaît pas sachez
qu'elles sont tournés mais qu'elles
sortiront tous les jours à 6 heures du
matin c'est comme ça dans les
commentaires vous pouvez aussi donner
d'autres idées connexes qu'ils vous font
penser à suivre par exemple des deux
livres dans le genre que vous aimez ou
de jeu dans le genre que vous aimez et
puis si cette vidéo vous appuyez
n'oubliez pas de la ligue avant de
partir de vous abonner si ce n'est pas
déjà fait ça se passe juste là ici dans
ce cercle là et moi je vous donne rendez
vous demain où nous ferons la deuxième
ouverture de ce calendrier de l'avent à
6h du matin wesh ses taux et c'est ça
qui est cool a semé un taux de change
il
[Musique]